SEASON FOR THE
COYOTES.
A 5-4 WIN ON
SATURDAY AGAINST
SESEA LITTLE
BIT ABOUM CLAYTON
KELLER, GOLIGOSKI,
WENT TO FOLIGNO
COYOTES.
IT'S MAYO FROM THEE
YOUNG DEFENSEMAN
FIRE
PLAYERS HAVE HAD
GREAT CAREERS AND
HALL OF FAMERS THAT
NEVER GOT THATS CALDER
TROPHY WINNER AND IT
COMES RIGHT TO HIM
AND HE RIPPED IT
AHEAD RIGHT THERE.S,
WHATATSPACE.
LOOKS UP, FINDS
STRALMAN WITH A
SHOT.
LOTS OF TRAFFIH AND THE.
>> THROWN IN BRODIN, LA
HE TEAM.
THEY HAVE SOME IMPRESSIVE GUYS
THAT HAVE TAKE
ORGANIZATION.
THIS ONE, HOW ABOUT
THAT.
BATTED OUT OF THE E  A
HOLDING ON AND
DRAWING A PENALTY.
KELLER TRIED TO SO GOOD
OUT THOSE HIPS.
ELSE, BEAGLE.
DARREN: ANOTHER
WIN --
BRENDAN: CROUSE.
HE'S IN
TRIES A LITTLE TOE
DRAG MOVE.
CROUSE IS AWARE OF
IT.
FOREHAND, BACKHAND
MINNESOTA.
CAPRICE SOLVE
PLAYING CATCH,
KEEPING IT UP HIGH.
NOW YOU WILL GO DOWNLY
HER MARK ON THIS FRANCHISE HERE
IN ARIZONA.
KAAPO KAHKONEN
PUSHES IT FURTHER
AWAY.
RIGHT IN FRONT FOR
CLAYTON KELLER, HI
BATTLE IT, AND IT'S
ONE COYOTE ON TWO.
MINNESOTA WILD.
OPENS UPLOSS I
YES.
OFF THE GLASS AND
OFF THE NETTING ANINSID
TO PLAY. DECISIVE IN
KIND OF IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NET.
YOU CAN SEE THIS
SHOT IS FIRED RIGHT